14800 3 au 31 décembre 2020 c'est le
nombre de lits dans les 478 maternités
françaises
un chiffre en baisse constante on en
comptait 15 1057 un an plus tôt en
décembre 2010 9 en un an dont 254 lignes
ont été supprimées fermetures de lits
mais aussi d'établissement une tendance
qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui en 2020
millich étaient répartis dans sept cent
quarante deux maternités différentes on
a finalement assisté du coup un
regroupement de maternité qui a généré
la création de maternité avec des
grosses grosses activités et c'est vrai
que pour les sages-femmes ça a été et
c'est toujours très très difficile
d'absorber ces excès d'activité on n'a
pas comment redistribuer tous les postes
de sages femmes des maternités qui ont
fermé sur les établissements qui ont
absorbé l'activité globale par la suite
donc c'est très compliqué de faire face
à ces afflux naissance dans des grosses
structures
au-delà du symbole de ces fermetures de
lits c'est toute une profession qui est
en souffrance depuis le début de l'année
2021 les sages femmes sont descendues
dans les rues pas moins de sept fois
manque d'effectif manque de
reconnaissance personnelle à bout la
liste des doléances s'allonge d'année en
année quand on dit qu'une seule sage
femme doit prendre en charge trois à
quatre femmes en même temps certains
disant ça va non dans un service
d'urgences ça ne va pas ça veut dire que
pendant qu'on consacre du temps à une
patiente les autres ne sont pas
accompagnés ni surveillées et donc les
sages femmes craignent à chaque fois
qu'ils aient des problèmes pour les
femmes qu'elles accompagnent et puis des
problèmes pour elle sur le plan médico
légal donc là c'est un véritable appel
au secours que l'on pousse parce que on
est dans des situations qui sont très
très compliquée et qui sont
amplifiées par le fait qu'on n'arrive
pas à recruter actuellement dans nos
maternités le 22 novembre dernier un
accord a été trouvé entre le
gouvernement et plusieurs syndicats de
la fédération hospitalière de france il
prévoit notamment une revalorisation
salariale
500 euros net par mois un taux de
promotion doublé et un temps de
formation allongée des avancées certes
mais qui constitue surtout un rattrapage
rappelons qu'avant le ségur la
rémunération des infirmiers français se
situer au 23e rang sur 29 des pays de l'
ocde et que les médecins salariés gagné
37 % de moins que leurs homologues
allemands par exemple mais quel qu'en
soit le montant c revalorisation ne
règle pas les problèmes des conditions
de travail nous ce qu'on demande c'est
ce qu'on a appelé un choc d'attractivité
pour la profession c'est à dire recruter
des futures sages-femmes donc des
recrutements au niveau de la formation
initiale donc là il ya une réponse
partielle qui est apportée en créant une
sixième année de formation pour les
futurs sages femmes
mais ces futures sages-femmes à la clé
de ces six années pour l'instant les
choses ne bougent pas on va être dans un
statut qui ne correspondra pas du tout à
ce haut degré de formation spécifique
vraiment aux sages femmes françaises les
accords conclus récemment sont des
accords salariaux certes mais en
l'absence de
comment mesures pour améliorer les
conditions de prise en charge dans les
maternités est donc une question
d'effectifs des sages-femmes pour
accompagner une patiente la
revalorisation salariale ne sera pas du
tout suffisante mais pour la plupart des
syndicats ces propositions sont bien
en-deça des attentes l'appel à la grève
a été maintenu pour le week-end du 26 au
29 novembre et une nouvelle semaine
noire de mobilisation serait envisagée
du 24 au 31 décembre objectif maintenir
la pression sur le gouvernement et
obtenir des garanties supplémentaires